ok let's get into audience questions for
the week three questions every week
first one today is from Brian brian says
hey David what evidence leads you to
believe people are fundamentally or
generally good like you and Joe Rogan
both said on the Joe Rogan show well so
this is a very old philosophical
question a question that exists even
beyond philosophy are we inherently good
or bad what about our greedy instincts
what about our selfless instincts what
about evolutionary advantages that one
or the other types of behavior conveys I
don't know that I have anything
particularly new to add to it I'll just
give you my take on it I believe people
are generally what I would call good
despite admittedly selfish and greedy
instincts that many of us have there's a
few actual data points if you want to
look at it there are some pretty good
studies from Harvard and Yale about what
are called first instincts in a variety
of different tests and people's
instincts overall tend to be towards
cooperation even if selfishness is in
the background as a motive sometimes for
that cooperation and that brings us to
what I think are some of the more
compelling sort of data points on this
which are evolutionary advantages humans
that better cooperate historically have
done best so in a sense there has been a
natural selection towards cooperation
and people that are sort of open to
acting in a way that benefits their
group even if underlying that are
selfish you're self-centered
interests and I think one of the really
interesting things about this is a lot
of the history on the evolutionary role
of religion and although I am not
religious myself and I believe that
modern religion is rife with problematic
ideas dogmatic blindly dogmatic thinking
defenses of violence justified by sacred
texts I mean all the people who watch
the show know my position on this I
actually do believe that
there are many points in history where
religious belief conferred an
evolutionary advantage where if you were
not in the in religious group it was
less likely that there would be sort of
cooperative relationships with the
people that you were living with whether
it's in a village or wherever else and
that those people tended to not do as
well
so yes selfish instincts exist but over
time nature in a sense has selected for
cooperative tendencies even if those
tendencies are rooted in some long term
plan that is selfish in other words well
I will act in a way that is cooperative
because I believe that that will
actually better serve me personally in
the long run well you're still
cooperating in that sense there are also
studies on babies which have found that
at really early points where we can even
get a sense of what is going on in the
baby's mind babies have an instinct for
fairness over unfairness as soon as they
can recognize it and they seem to prefer
good over evil they don't like
unfairness in puppet shows at very early
ages they tend away from violence at
very early ages and in the end
statistically most people are not
violent people who are committing acts
of violence in the real world most
people are not criminals as defined by
society most people lie mostly only in
the sense of white lies people do not
like and react positively to news of
criminality or violence or war or
terrorism or conflict and certainly
they're not participating in it
themselves so of course reality is
complex evil exists to the extent that
that's what we want to call it
radicalization exists but I believe
people most people are fundamentally and
generally good it's been not only
informed by my personal experience but
also by all of the different data points
that I've mentioned here all of which
are widely available for you to find
disagree with me let me know are people
fundamentally not good are people
fundamentally bad or evil or violent or
whatever
I'd love to hear from you about this